hi i'm jennifer hudson and i play aretha
franklin in respect and i'm here with
buzzfeed to talk about my first time
oh my god my first album i ever bought
it was probably something like voice to
men or invoke or voices you remember
voices yeah yeah yeah i can't remember
that far back but i think somewhere up
in there or maybe a gospel album wow my
first memory of listening to aretha
franklin it may have been like mary
don't you weep from one of her gospel
albums because i'm a church girl and i
grew up in a church and for a long time
all we could listen to was church songs
okay so probably mary don't you weep but
the most memorable that i remember
hearing people talk about was dr feel
good okay
the first time i met aretha franklin i
was eliminated from american idol and i
got to open up for her in maryville
indiana in her concert i was the opening
act of that show and i also got to sit
there and watch her sing from the
backstage view and all my family came
out this was like in 2003 i want to say
i remember giving her flowers i remember
taking a photo with her aretha was very
quiet she didn't say much back then and
thanking her for allowing me to sing and
i was like wow she even let me sing back
then i got a photo that's what i
remember most the first time i realized
i wanted to be a performer was oh
watching all my grandmother sing in
church my cousin sing in church and
begging for a solo in church i would go
from the organist to the pianist like
can i sing can i sing can i sing and
then when it came time for me to sing i
got stage fright and couldn't remember
the words and the congregation had to
help me out chad i was terrified by the
time it was time to sing my first real
and only job
was working at burger king and i used to
sing to the customers in the drive-thru
on a little microphone beep beep when it
beeped oh that was my moment my
opportunity to sing them people down as
they made their order in the driveway i
would like have a song to sing and then
from there turns out the manager of
burger king was a club promoter and so
he started to hire me to sing for his
club events and i ended up making more
money singing one song for that then i
did working at burger king and that is
when i quit working at burger king i
said i'm gonna make my living using my
gift and that's what i've been doing
ever since what the first time i
realized i was famous
the only thing i could think of i think
this is the first time i realized my
star power how about that the dream girl
all the dream mats on the stage we were
shooting move and in between the tape
like the audience would be like hey you
know scream out beyonce or nika and
jennifer and i went to wade like oh hey
and from me waving like the reaction
everybody was like and i was like
then i looked at my hand nose and i
waved again and they just went crazy and
i was like well what is that i'm like
that star power like that's when it was
like the power of stardom i guess it
creeped me out too though when people
cry on you
first behind the same memory of american
idol i would rehearse i like stairwells
we used to be at cbs studios we will all
find a little nook to rehearse in and i
will always go hide in the stairwell
most of my rehearsals is in a stairwell
or a bathroom okay because the acoustics
is amazing you could be in your solitude
and sing so i would go in the stairwell
george would be in the hallway and we
will find little nooks george huff hands
down and we still work together george
huss was my first friend that i've made
on the set of america i don't i have to
tell you this story because we were in
pasadena california i don't know what is
narrowed down to at this point maybe the
top 130 i don't know and we're all
outside and i had big hair that's why i
have big hair right now because i'm
paying homage to when the world first
met me although everybody keeps saying i
look like whitney houston i accept it i
didn't even know that but i was trying
to go back to jennifer hudson big hair
anyway so i had the big hair and a big
presence according to george i went to
speak to him and he screams at me like
he's so excited he falls on his head
oh my god and i was like okay walk away
from him he's crazy
and i promise you guys spoke to me in
that moment and said go back and talk to
that boy and i'm so glad that i did
because george huff to this day is one
of my best friends my vocal arranger now
and he is a part of a huge part of
j-hope productions well first of all
before i start with the first impression
how crazy is that jamie foxx is like my
favorite male actor beyonce is my
favorite female artist and then to end
up in a film with them that's nothing
but god like what that blew me away
again the first time i met beyonce was
when i was literally in the middle of
choreography rehearsal with fatima
robinson four dream girls and walks this
pretty pretty girl and i'm like oh my
gosh she's so pretty oh my god that is
beyonce i know what and i lost sight of
everything every step fatima had taught
me jamie my first time meeting him was
in the middle of a scene of dream girls
it was we are a family thing and walks
jamie and i had to kiss him i was like
well can i at least say hello like i've
never met him this is my first film so
that was a little weird that was a lot
for a first timer and to meet like jamie
foxx and the introduction's like okay
kids action kiss huh
once i brought it home i
don't know what i did with it all i
remember is after leaving like the after
parties of the oscars set on my
nightstand right beside me in my hotel
room i fell asleep looking at it even to
this day i still every blue moon go sit
by it and be like that's my because it's
still kind of surreal it is but it sits
on a ward wall in my home right now and
it sits in the center of all the other
awards and it says
thank you buzzfeed make sure you see
respect august 13th
[Music]
you